GROUPTHINK REGARDLESS OF THE
CONTINENT WE ARE BROADCASTING
FROM.
WE WILL BE BACK.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY,"
WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT,
ONE PERSON IS EMERGING AS THE
CLEAR WINNER FROM THIS WEEK'S
DEMOCRATIC DEBATES, THAT WOULD
BE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE RADICAL RADICAL SOCIALIST ON
STAGE IT DID NOT DELIVER, NO ONE
WAS IMPRESSED WITH ANYONE.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED THE DEBATE
"BORING," BILL MAHER TWEETED
"NOT A PROMISING START."
EVEN THE CONGRESSWOMAN, THE REAL
LEADER OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ AND
CHIMING IN, COMPARING IT TO A
HIGH SCHOOL CLASSROOM FILLED
WITH KIDS WHO DIDN'T DO THEIR
HOMEWORK, DIDN'T READ THE BOOK.
IN A MOMENT WE WILL BREAK DOWN
ALL THE RADICAL POSITIONS.
YOU GET TO HEAR IT YOURSELF,
ILL-INFORMED PLATFORMS, FAR LEFT
FANTASIES THAT WOULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
ALSO, MY STAFF BEHIND MY BACK
CENTER OWNER LAWRENCE JONES TO
THE DEBATE IN MIAMI TO SEE WHAT
DEMOCRATS THINK ABOUT ME.
I WAS JUST TOLD ABOUT THIS
MOMENTS AGO.
I CAN HARDLY WAIT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SEAN, NOT A FAN.
[LAUGHS]
>> WE ARE GOING TO PLAY THE
PULLED        FULL
PACKAGE COMING UP, I'M TOLD IT
WILL BE QUITE
ENTERTAINING, BUT WE TURN TO ONE
OF THE BIGGEST LOSERS FROM LAST
NIGHTS DEBATE, THAT WOULD BE A
MBC NEWS.
THEY EXPERIENCED SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE DEBATE, CAN HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY, TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK WE HAD A LITTLE
MICROPHONE ISSUE IN THE BACK --
>> CONTROL ROOM --
>> WE HAVE THE AUDIENCE,
ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE A ROLE FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PLAY IN ORDER TO
GET THESE GUNS OFF THE STREETS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
HAPPENING?
>> WE ARE HEARING OUR
COLLEAGUES' AUDIO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IF THE CONTROL ROOM COULD
TURN OFF THE MICROPHONES OF THE
PREVIOUS MODERATORS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE HAVE PREPARED FOR
EVERYTHING.
WE DID NOT PREPARE FOR THIS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A QUICK
BREAK, WE ARE GETTING THIS
TECHNICAL SITUATION FIXED, WE
WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> Sean: TECHNICAL GLITCHES,
THEY DO HAPPEN.
REMEMBER, ONCE WE HAD AN ANCHOR?
IT WAS CALLED GOING TO THE
BATHROOM, FLUSHING THE TOILET.
THAT WASN'T RELEASED ON TAPE, IT
HAPPENS.
THE REAL EMBARRASSMENT IS THAT
NBC ALLOWED THE BIGGEST
CONSPIRACY THEORIST IN THE
COUNTRY TO MODERATE THE DEBATE.
THE SO CALL NEWS NETWORK PUT
ROSWELL RACHEL MADDOW RIGHT
THERE FRONT AND CENTER.
THE SINGLE BIGGEST CONSPIRACY
THEORIST IN THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE GOING TO GO OVER A LOT OF
THESE CONSPIRACIES, JUST A QUICK
LIST.
SHE WENT DESCRIBED HERSELF AS A
LEFT OF MAO, SHE HAS BEEN
BREATHLESSLY
REPORTING AN ACTUAL HOAX AND
SHE TOLD HER VIEWERS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS A RUSSIAN
OP, REX TILLERSON, RUSSIAN PLAN,
SAYING VLADIMIR PUTIN COULD TURN
OFF THE POWER IN FARGO,
NORTH DAKOTA, WHENEVER HE
WANTED.
COMPARING TRUMP'S CHILDREN --
HIS OWN, LIBERAL KINDNESS -- TWO
HIS OWN, LIBERAL KINDNESS -- TWT
SADDAM HUSSEIN'S KIDS.
RAMPANT BIAS, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, HATRED ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP, NBC NEWS ALLOWED
HER TO BE THE MODERATOR.
ME, RUSH, MARK LIVE IN, HOW
ABOUT O'REILLY CUSTOMER OF THE
FOUR OF US WILL DO THE NEXT
DEBATE.
BUT IN NBC IS NOT INTERESTED IN
THE TRUTH, INTEGRITY OR ACTUAL
JOURNALISM, NBC NEWS, ARE YOU
WATCHING?
A TV CHANNEL THAT WORKS IN
UNISON WITH EVERYTHING
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, EVERYTHING
SOCIALIST, EVERYTHING TO
SNEER,'S MANTLE, PRESIDENT TRUMP
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
AND RACHEL MADDOW AND HER
SIDEKICK, THEY DIDN'T ASK TOUGH
QUESTIONS.
WE NEVER EXPECTED THAT, INSTEAD
THEY ENCOURAGED THE FANS ON THE
STAGE INDULGE THEIR FAR LEFT
CONSPIRACY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE ARE HERE IN MIAMI WHICH IS
ALREADY EXPERIENCING SERIOUS
FLOODING ON SUNNY DAYS AS A
RESULT OF SEA LEVEL RISE.
PART OF MIAMI BEACH COULD BE
UNDERWATER IN OUR LIFETIMES.
DOESN'T YOUR PLAN SAVE MIAMI?
IMPEACHMENT WILL NOT BE PURSUED
IN THE HOUSE, IT RAISES
THE PROSPECT AND THE MUELLER
REPORT RAISES THE PROSPECT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD BE
PROSECUTED FOR SOME OF THOSE
POTENTIAL CRIMES AND DOWN THE.
NO U.S. PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
PROSECUTED FOR TIMES AFTER
LEAVING OFFICE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD OR COULD
BE THE FIRST?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, ANYWAY.
ONE NEWS CRITIC ACTUALLY CALLED
ROSWELL RACHEL MADDOW'S FORMANTS
LOST FOR JOURNALISM.
BUT WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU SENT
'07 '08, JOURNALISM HAS BEEN
LOST FOR MANY YEARS.
MSNBC, CONSPIRACY TV, NO ATTEMPT
EVER REVIVED THAT.
STILL, LAST NIGHT'S DEBATE
CONFIRMS WHAT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
TELLING YOU FOR SOME TIME.
MODERATES AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THEY ARE EXTINCT.
THEY NO LONGER EXIST.
THERE ARE NO MORE JOE
LIEBERMAN'S, RADICAL SOCIALIST
HAVE COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
TAKEN OVER, AND LAST NIGHT THEY
WERE JUST OBSESSED WITH
VILIFYING PRIVATE ENTERPRISE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT WHICH HAS
CREATED THE GREATEST STANDARD OF
LIVING IN THE INDUSTRIALIZED
WORLD, THAT HAS ADVANCED THE
HUMAN CONDITION MORE THAN ANY
GOVERNMENTAL SYSTEM.
CAPITALISM WORKS AND WE SHARE IT
WITH OTHERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHO IS THIS ECONOMY REALLY
WORKING FOR?
IT'S DOING GREAT FOR THINNER AND
THINNER SLICE AT THE TOP.
WE NEED TO MAKE STRUCTURAL
CHANGE IN OUR GOVERNMENT AND OUR
ECONOMY AND IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> WOULD YOU SUPPORT A 70%
INDIVIDUAL MARGINAL TAX BREAK?
YES, NO, OR PASS?
>> I WOULD SUPPORT A TAX BREAK
AND A TAX CODE THAT IS FAIR FOR
EVERYONE.
TAX CAPITAL AT THE SAME RATE YOU
TAX ORDINARY INCOME.
TAKE THAT NORMAL TAX RATE UP TO
28%.
>> WE HAVE A REAL PROBLEM WITH
CORPORATE CONSOLIDATION.
YOU SEE THE EVIDENCE AND THAT
AND HOW DIGNITY IS BEING
STRIPPED FROM LABOR.
>> 70% TAX RATE ON THE WEALTHY.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BREAK UP BIG
CORPORATIONS WHEN THEY ARE NOT
SERVING OUR DEMOCRACY!
THERE ARE PLENTY MILLIONS IN
THIS COUNTRY, IT'S JUST IN THE
WRONG HANDS.
>> Sean: I DIDN'T KNOW WHO
HALF THESE PEOPLE WERE.
THEY WANT A TOP 70% MARGINAL TAX
RATE FOR INDIVIDUALS, 90% TOP
CORPORATE TAX RATE.
THEN A WEALTH TAX, THEN A DEATH
TAX.
WOW, WHO IS GOING TO WANT TO
BUILD BUSINESS?
I WONDER WHY NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, LET'S SAY ILLINOIS,
CALIFORNIA ARE LOSING POPULATIO
POPULATION?
YEAH, BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
PROPOSED LAST NIGHT.
WHERE ARE WE GOING TO GO NEXT?
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH, BY THE
WAY, IF YOU LOOK AT IT,
BILLIONAIRES AND MILLIONAIRES IN
THE WORLD TO PAY FOR THIS
GRANDIOSE SOCIALIST VISION OF
THEIRS.
LET'S SEE, BASIC INCOME,
RETIREMENT, EARLY EDUCATION,
CHILD EDUCATION,
UNIVERSAL CHILD CARE, FAMILY
LEAVE, GUARANTEED VACATION, FREE
HOUSING, AND OF COURSE FOR
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE, BUT YOU
CAN'T PICK YOUR DOCTOR AND SAVE
MONEY.
THAT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
OF COURSE, THERE WILL BE NO
CHOICES, WE ALL LIVE IN ONE
SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNMENT SYSTEM.
>> WHO HERE WOULD ABOLISH THEIR
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE IN
FAVOR OF A GOVERNMENT RUN PLAN?
A SHOW OF HANDS TO START OUT
WITH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> YES, I AM FOR MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
A LOT OF POLITICIANS SAY IT'S
JUST NOT POSSIBLE, WE JUST CAN'T
DO IT, HAVE A LOT OF POLITICAL
REASONS FOR THIS.
WHAT THEY ARE REALLY TELLING YOU
IS THAT THEY JUST WON'T FIGHT
FOR IT.
>> WOULD YOU REPLACE PRIVATE
INSURANCE?
>> NO, I THINK THE CHOICE IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR ABILITY --
>> PRIVATE INSURANCE IS NOT
WORKING FOR TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE CO-PAYS, DEDUCTIBLES, THE
PREMIUMS, THE OUT-OF-POCKET
EXPENSES, IT'S NOT WORKING!
HOW CAN YOU DEFEND SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT WORKING?
>> Sean: ELIZABETH WARREN GET
ELECTED, HER FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS WOULD BE TO BAN PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
THAT'S RIGHT, IF YOU'RE WATCHING
AT HOME AND YOU LIKE YOUR
INSURANCE AND YOU LIKE YOUR
DOCTOR, TOO BAD BECAUSE IF
ELECTED, ELIZABETH WARREN WILL
BE MAKING AND ALLOWING THE
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE ALL YOUR
HEALTH CARE DECISIONS, AND YOU
THOUGHT OBAMACARE WAS BAD?
HOW MANY LOST MILLIONS LOST
THEIR DOCTORS?
MILLIONS LOST THEIR PLANS?
EVERYONE PAID A TONE MORE
DESPITE OF THE PROMISES.
GIVEN ELIZABETH WARREN'S TRACK
RECORD OF FAKING HER ETHNICITY I
DON'T THINK SHE HAS THE BEST
JUDGMENT, BUT OF COURSE THE TRUE
LITMUS TEST IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THAT IS THE USUAL
ABORTION AND OPEN BORDERS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IN SOME CASES, THEY HAVE
OUTRIGHT INFANTICIDE THEY ARE
ENDORSING.
LAST NIGHT, THE PARTY OF
PARTIAL, SOME CASES, YES, DURING
AND EVEN POST BIRTH ABORTION.
THEY SHOWED THEIR TRUE COLORS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ONLY IN
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM, I BELIEVE
IN REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT JUST
BECAUSE A WOMAN, OR LET'S ALSO
NOT FORGET SOMEONE IN THE
TRANSIT COMMUNITY, A TRANS
FEMALE -- IS POOR, IT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE THE
RIGHT TO EXERCISE THAT RIGHT TO
CHOOSE.
>> SENATOR WARREN, WOULD YOU PUT
ANY LIMITS ON ABORTION?
>> I WOULD MAKE CERTAIN THAT
EVERY WOMAN HAS ACCESS TO THE
FULL RANGE OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
WE NOW HAVE IN AMERICA WHERE
MOST PEOPLE SUPPORT
ROE VS. WADE, WE NEED TO MAKE
THAT FEDERAL LAW.
>> Sean: JUST TO KEEP TRACK IF
YOU ARE AT HOME, TO ADD IT ALL
UP, DEMOCRATIC RADICAL
SOCIALIST, THEY ARE PROMISING
EVERYTHING FOR YOU.
THROUGH THE ROOF, GOVERNMENT
HEALTH CARE, AND A PRIVATE
INSURANCE OPTIONS, NO LIMITS ON
ABORTION AT ALL REGARDLESS OF
THE STAGE OF PREGNANCY OR
SURVIVABILITY OF THE CHILD AT
THAT POINT.
EXTREME POSITIONS, NOT BASED IN
REALITY AND IN MANY CASES SCARY,
BUT THERE IS MORE.
ONE KEY TENANT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PLATFORM, OPEN BORDERS.
ONE CANDIDATE VILIFIED
REPUBLICANS TO TRY TO DETER
PEOPLE FROM ENTERING THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, AND OF
COURSE, CHILDREN FOR MAKING THE
DANGEROUS TRIP THROUGH THE
BORDER.
IT WASN'T LONG OBAMA WAS ECHOING
THE CONCERNS OF REPUBLICANS,
SOMETIMES IT SOUNDED LIKE TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ARE MESSAGES ABSOLUTELY DON'T
SEND YOUR CHILDREN UNACCOMPANIED
ON TRAINS OR THROUGH A BUNCH OF
SMUGGLERS.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW MANY OF
THESE KIDS DON'T MAKE IT MAY
HAVE BEEN WAYLAID INTO
SEX TRAFFICKING OR KILLED
BECAUSE THEY FELL OFF THE TRAIN.
WE HAVE NO WAY OF TRACKING THAT
SO THAT IS OUR DIRECT MESSAGE TO
THE FAMILIES IN CENTRAL AMERICA.
DO NOT SEND YOUR CHILDREN TO THE
BORDERS.
IF THEY DO MAKE IT, THEY WILL
GET SENT BACK.
MORE IMPORTANT, THEY MAY NOT
MAKE IT.
>> Sean: YOU MIGHT REMEMBER
THE DEMOCRATS EXPRESSED NO
OUTRAGE OVER THOSE COMMENTS.
IN FACT, THERE WAS LITTLE
OUTRAGE OVER THE NASTY
DEPORTATIONS UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE THOSE PICTURES THAT WE
SHOW TO YOU.
THE FIRST WITH DONALD TRUMP.
REMEMBER THE CONDITIONS UNDER
OBAMA?
MIGRANT HOLDING FACILITIES?
ALL UNDER OBAMA.
NO ANGER WHEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOR CHILDREN --
YEAH -- IN CAGES.
FAKE MORAL OUTRAGE IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S FAVORITE
POLITICAL WEAPON.
WE SOUGHT OVER RUSSIA AND THE
COLLUSION HOAX.
THEY CALLED TRUMP A RUSSIAN
OPERA BUT REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
HILLARY CLINTON'S DIRTY BOUGHT A
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, PLAYED IN THE
SPYING SCANDAL OF AN OPPOSITION
PARTY CANDIDATE, THAN A
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND A PRESIDENT.
WE SAW IT IN THE 33,000
SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
THEY ARE NOW OBSESSED WITH
PHANTOM CHARGES AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT WITH NO UNDERLYING
CRIME.
YET, WITH HILLARY CLINTON, ACID
WASH, DELETE 33,000 EMAILS,
HAMMERS, REMOVING SIM CARDS.
NOT A PEEP FROM THE MEDIA MOB OR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE SEE IT ON ISSUES OF RACISM
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
DON'T FORGET THE DEMOCRATIC
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA.
YEAH, THEY ARE STILL BOTH IN
OFFICE.
WE SEE IT ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
AT LAST NIGHT, FOUR OF THE
CANDIDATES ONSTAGE SAID THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO OUR NATION.
ONCE AT DONALD TRUMP.
I ASSUME THEY ALL FLEW IN A
PLANE TO LAST NIGHT'S DEBATE.
I HIGHLY TOOK THEY TOOK UP HE IS
FROM THE AIRPORT EITHER.
BUT IT IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
MORAL COMPASS,
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, GETS
HER WAY, WE ARE GOING TO BAN
AIRPLANES AND COWS, THE
COMBUSTION ENGINE, THE LIFEBLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY ARE ABSOLUTELY
GONE.
YOU GET THE PICTURE,
OCASIO-CORTEZ WEIGHING IN ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
SHE IS NOT HAPPY WITH THE
CURRENT FRONT RUNNER.
IN FACT, OCASIO-CORTEZ JUST
TRASHED SLEEPY, CREEPY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN INTO AN INTERVIEW
SAYING THAT THE 76 ROLLED FORMER
VP WOULD DEPRESS
TURNOUT AND IS NOT A
PRAGMATIC CHOICE.
I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH HER FOR
ONCE.